[Music]
welcome back to Hannity is we continue
now with the author of killing England
you know and while Bill O'Reilly is with
us so I want to go back to this point
because you talked about being a
cultural warrior the NFL is a cultural
issue when we're talking about tearing
down memorials or breaking up history or
acting as though it didn't happen right
I always say bill that this is the
greatest country God has given man that
is a cumulated more power and never
abused it less and used its power to
advance the human condition so here's my
question for you you talk in this book
about once you break down those cultural
institutions really they're setting the
country up to say that the whole country
is predicated on evil white supremacy
that's and the Constitution is their
target yeah I want you to explain and
compare it to what you say in the book
and the parallels so I came out with
killing England a week ago almost the
same day the Dallas Texas School Board
started debating whether to remove the
names of George Washington Thomas
Jefferson and Benjamin Franklin from
their schools
how shocking is that so on the cover of
my book you have Washington Jefferson
and Franklin and we tell you who they
are as men as people both the good and
the bad by the way very blunt very yummy
Ben Franklin give one example well Ben
Franklin was the Hugh Hefner of his time
I mean when you feel it there's one way
to say it bill right yeah and I'm the
energy this guy had talked about the
kite that wasn't a half of it but anyway
you got it you got it
who's gonna stop this madness you you
the American people you have to go to
the Dallas school board meeting and you
have to say I know who George Washington
was and Thomas Jefferson yes they were
slaveholders but this is what they did
to give Hannity and O'Reilly the freedom
to talk to millions of people but this
is how they suffered they heard but look
all have sinned and fallen short every
man every man has rusted and fallen
short and I look at myself first guilty
as charged
no country is perfect
I think the most intriguing thing that
never gets talked about of our founders
and our framers is they created a system
unlike any other right where they built
into the system
the ability of the people we the people
to right wrongs to end evil and correct
in justices and history bill has proven
it worked and you should see the price
they paid the price that you'll be
washing contain for eight years of war
against the king the one flaw was
slavery but in the Civil War hundreds of
thousands of whites died died to free
the slaves so this isn't a white
supremacist nation this is the biggest
bunch of bull I've ever heard so I want
to get people I want to make them armed
and dangerous with facts Reid killing
England you'll know they were you know
why this country as you say is the
greatest country ever you know six
hundred and fifty plus thousand people
lost their lives in the wars in this
country yeah and and and that's why many
of them fought under that flag bill they
fought under that flag and that goes
back to the NFL issue where we started
you know one of the things that I care
at this point in my life more than
anything else I just want the former
dishwasher cook busboy waiter bartender
tile layer house painter paper hanger
and framer and roofer well you got a lot
of jobs and I together that's 20 years
of my life I want everybody to have the
shot that we saw and and if you work
hard get educated and really figure out
your talent you'll make it in America
you'll make it here and the people who
are telling you you won't make it cuz
you're black or you're Hispanic they're
lying to you and they're giving you an
excuse to fail now that's racism Burgess
Owens was on my grade I did I heard it
and he said the exact same thing I said
don't give him an excuse total million
he said millionaires shouldn't tell
people that they can't make it he's
right you know you have to have
perspective you have to have
informed decision if you want a descent
I respect that's Hannity respects to
make our living on it but be informed
don't be telling me that cops in America
go out every day trying to hunt down
black people that's a lie they don't so
be informed and make your points on
dissent in a way that's rational the
country needs and this goes back to
those that want to silence conservative
voices this goes back to we have more
dialogue more debate more information I
think people do better you know what the
real sad thing is it's things you said
on your show you write in your books and
things I'm saying on this show nobody
else in media says it no because you got
what you get attacked I don't care about
the attack I know you don't I don't you
and you're a special case though but
most people don't want their families
attack it's hard all right then go after
your families that come on your property
they lie about you they pay people to
lie about you my poor daughter calls me
that I dad they put up a video of you
vaping in a smoking opium wasn't in room
I saw it you know and I said sweetheart
I said for 16 years of your life I never
told you what I lived through I know I
know what to bring it to their attention
no it's worse than ever here's what I
want to ask you because we're running
out of time and I appreciate you coming
in and good luck was the talk of you two
having it tell me something you gotta
miss the grind a lot you come on you
don't miss the swamp a little I I'm
afraid of those water moccasins that
look I did 20 years and six months here
and it was when you work with outside
edition fabulous of ABC all the other I
work at ABC CBS Inside Edition but this
was far and away the best job because I
got to meet some of the folks I might
who knows what I'm gonna do I don't know
I enjoyed my summer off I the vitriol
that you have to face and then oh I have
to face and I got our evaluated you know
I had any I are going fishing and you
guys don't know that about fishing all
right no but you you were my radio show
yelling at the fish and I water today I
know but when we're out and fishing
we're gonna we're gonna figure this out
but there has to be now there has to be
an exposition by people like you and me
about what's really
happening in this country because it's
dangerous they want to take freedom of
speech away from their opponents they
the far-left
I contend that the future this country
is at stake in ways we don't know and if
they're successful in taking out this
president for reasons for that aren't
worth the G this is the only this is it
this is it this network goes they win
all right bill will come back we come
back maybe I maybe fishing first are you
coming back oh come back this book man
that's true